♪ ♪
>> Brian: THE MUELLER REPORT
HAS BEEN FINISHED FOR ABOUT FOUR
MONTHS, AND A MATTER OF PUBLIC
RECORD FOR ABOUT FOUR YEARS IT
SEEMS.
FOUND NO EVIDENCE THAT TRUMP
COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA IN 2016.
BUT DON'T LET THAT GET IN THE
WAY.
THAT'S WHY HE IS STILL PRESIDENT
RIGHT NOW.
DON'T LET THAT GET IN THE WAY.
IN HOLLYWOOD CANNOT ACCEPT THAT
THAT NEVER GETS OUT OF THE WAY.
CONSTRUCTING A NEW ALTERNATIVE
UNIVERSE TO LIVE IN.
IT IS A NEW VIDEO FOR
TOM STEYER'S PRO-IMPEACHMENT
GROUP, SEVERAL CELEBRITIES IN A
FEW DIFFERENT STATES ARE
PRETENDING TO AUDITION IN A ROLE
FOR AN UPCOMING MUELLER MOVIE
THAT WILL NEVER HAPPEN.
WATCH.
TO SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT
STATED --
>> I NEED LOYALTY.
>> I EXPECT LOYALTY.
>> WHAT?
OKAY.
>> CAN YOU IMAGINE IF THIS IS
FROM THE REAL REPORT?
>> IT IS.
>> REALLY?
>> SERIOUSLY.
>> >> [BLEEP].
>> THAT IS THE REAL MUELLER
REPORT?
>> HE TOLD THE FBI DIRECTOR THAT
HE NEEDED LOYALTY.
>> GET THE [BLEEP] OUT.
>> Brian: CREATING THE MEGA
COMEDY TOUR AROUND THE COUNTRY,
MICHAEL, WHAT IS GOING ON WITH
YOUR PEOPLE, THESE ARE THE
HOLLYWOOD PEOPLE THAT YOU HANG
OUT WITH.
>> THEY HAVE LOST THEIR MINDS.
THEY HAVE LOST THEIR MINDS.
YOU ARE WITNESSING WHAT THE LEFT
DOES BEST.
TWO GOOD THINGS.
ONE IS ORGANIZED FICTION, TWO IS
WASTE MONEY.
SO THIS IS ACTUALLY BOTH.
WE HAVE DEBRA MESSING PRETENDING
THAT SHE HAS NEVER HEARD OF THE
MUELLER REPORT.
THIS IS THE MUELLER REPORT, WHAT
IN THE SAM HILL?
COME ON, HONEY, SHE TWEETS MORE
THAN THE PRESIDENT.
SHE TWEETS LIKE SHE HAS STOCK IN
TWITTER.
IT IS OUTRAGEOUS.
>> Brian: THEY THOUGHT THE
MUELLER REPORT WOULD FINALLY
FREE THEM FROM DONALD TRUMP.
IT IS OUT.
IT DID NOT.
HE WILL COME TO TOWN ON THE
17TH.
IN A COUPLE OF WEEKS.
SO WE WILL HAVE ANOTHER PAGE,
ANOTHER CHAPTER, BUT MAYBE YOU
CAN EXPLAIN THIS TO ME, JOHN
LITHGOW AND OTHERS WHO WERE
AUDITIONING, DOING THIS FAKE
AUDITION, WHAT DO THEY PLAN ON
ACCOMPLISHING?
IS THIS THERAPY WE ARE
WITNESSING?
>> I THINK THEY ARE TRYING TO
GET EVERY LITTLE PIECE OF
EMOTION OUT OF THIS.
THEY WANT TO CONTINUE TO SCARE
AMERICA.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS ALL ABOUT.
IT IS A FAKE AUDITION FOR A FAKE
MOVIE BASED ON A REPORT THAT WAS
BASED ON A FAKE DOSSIER, IT IS
THE FAKE TRIFECTA.
SO ALL THEY CAN TRY TO DO IS
SCARE PEOPLE AND LITHGOW DID HIS
BEST.
HE WAS PUTTING A SPIN ON IT.
THE LINE WAS ANSWER THE PHONE,
AND LITHGOW WAS LIKE "ANSWER THE
PHONE" LIKE IT WAS THIRD ROCK
FROM THE SUN.
I WANT TO DO MY OWN VERSION OF
THIS.
I WANT TO DO DRAMATIC READINGS
OF THE CLINTON IMPEACHMENT
TESTIMONY.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
YOU COULD GET
ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER TO BE THE
PRESIDENT, YOU KNOW, I DID NOT
HAVE RELATIONS WITH THAT WOMAN.
I DID NOT DO IT.
YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE ME.
>> Brian: SO MY GOAL.
>> IT WOULD BE GREAT.
>> Brian: YOU WOULD NOT DO
THAT, I KNOW YOU ARE KIDDING,
BECAUSE YOU HAVE A LIFE, A
CAREER, AND A FAMILY.
HE WOULD NOT BE OBSESSED WITH
SOMEBODY YOU HAVE NEVER MET.
BUT YOU CAME OUT AND HAD THE
COURAGE TO COME OUT.
YOU TOLD THE WORLD THAT YOU
VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP.
HOW HAS YOUR LIFE CHANGED SINCE?
>> THANKFULLY MY CIRCLE OF
FRIENDS, THEY ARE GOOD PEOPLE.
EVEN MY LIBERAL FRIENDS, THEY
HAVE NOT TOTALLY FREAKED OUT.
IT IS THE WEIRDOS FROM LIKE
HIGH SCHOOL AND COLLEGE ON
FACEBOOK WHO ARE LIKE, THEY ARE
JUST IN SHOCK.
PEOPLE WHO ARE ANTI-TRUMP ARE
JUST GETTING LIKE A FREE GYM
MEMBERSHIP.
THEY WATCH THESE PROGRAMS IN
THEIR HEART RATE GOES UP SO
FAST.
IT'S LIKE THEY ARE GETTING A
WORKOUT.
THEY NEED TO RELAX.
>> Brian: I DON'T WANT TO
BRING BUSINESS INTO THE WORLD OF
ACTING AND ART, BUT THERE ARE
MORE MOVIES BEING DONE, MORE
INVESTMENT HAPPENING, MORE
OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE THE
ECONOMY IS THRIVING.
YOU MIGHT NOT WANT TO GIVE HIM
CREDIT, BUT YOU MIGHT NOT WANT
TO TURN THE PAGE IN A YEAR,
BECAUSE WE KNOW WHAT WE LEFT WE
KNOW IT COULD BE STRAIGHT-AHEAD.
MICHAEL, I WILL WATCH YOU WANT
TO WORK, FOLLOW YOU AROUND LIKE
A CRAZY FAN BOY AS YOU GO ON